this says this still
it's such a cool image to me these two
top uh sportsmen top chess players in
the world sitting here fighting in a big
final
with uh you know 25 000 is for the
winner it's a trophy and they're eating
takeaway it's just you never you don't
see that in any other sport i think it
must be
some sort of other esport
actually it'll be interesting for
followers out there of other esports
does this happen regularly do they just
whip out some noodles halfway through
the game
i guess you can't i guess you're so
occupied with the mouse i guess the
mouse and whatever it is
he's diving in there yeah yeah he's deep
diving into his into his noodles and uh
something with rice it looks like yeah
he's getting free he's getting shoveling
it in there
this needs the energy
this is where chess players differ
because i mentioned yesterday on the
show i hate playing
when i've got a full belly i just can't
focus i feel a bit lethargic a bit tired
but bloated but magnus he we've seen it
he loves eating during the games plus it
must be so nice to celebrate with a nice
meal after you played exactly gives you
something to look forward to yeah
but uh no magnus we saw actually on last
season uh of the meltwater champions
chess tour his eating habits they did
distract him slightly often blunders
came immediately after he'd started
eating